appeler à l'aide
je regarderai d'ici je m'assurerai que tu
dises que tu sais que tu pourrais lutter contre ça je peux
dire que courir vers le ghetto était mon
idée
mon père croirait que tout est
je suis imprudent il y a beaucoup d'influence
volonté et  trouvez-vous un avocat, vous pouvez passer un
accord avec ces chronométreurs Je suis presque
sûr que le chronométreur ne fait pas d'accords
juste au cas où
s'il vous plaît déposez
Silvia vous ne pourriez pas épargner un deuxième
père J'aimerais pouvoir dire que je suis surpris
que vous ayez entendu  ce que je viens de dire non je fais
n'importe quoi pour toi ils viennent te chercher
toi